[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue à vous regarde en
direct je suis ravie de vous retrouver
au sommaire ce soir les violences
sexuelles et sexistes en politique à
faire Bayou à faire catenens à ton
basculer dans l'ère du grand déballage
comment faire primer la parole des
femmes sans tomber dans
l'instrumentalisation jusqu'où appliquer
le principe de précaution et puis les
cellules d'écoute des partis politiques
sont-elles efficaces le garde des sceaux
les mettent en cause directement ce soir
on en parle dans un instant dans notre
grand débat notre grand témoin ce soir
est un grand diplomate il a été
ambassadeur de France aux États-Unis en
Israël ou encore aux Nations Unies il
nous dira dans quel monde nous sommes
entrés à l'heure où Vladimir Poutine
organise des référendums d'annexion en
Ukraine et menace de l'arme nucléaire
Gérard arrot signe histoire diplomatique
chez Grasset et il est notre invité ce
soir enfin nous retrouverons nos
affranchis ce soir le parti pris de Léa
chamboncelle sur la victoire de Georgia
la candidate d'extrême droite en Italie
le grand reporter Vincent Huger pourquoi
la mobilisation partielle en Russie est
déjà par terre et puis le regard de
Stéphanie Despierre sur le boycott des
députés insoumis de l'équipe de foot de
l'Assemblée pour protester contre la
présence de joueurs du RN voilà pour le
menu c'est parti
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs crises à Europe Écologie
Les Verts crise à la France insoumise
qu'elle soit psychologique sexuelle ou
sexiste la question des violences
ébranles les partis politiques Eric
Dupond-Moretti garde des sceaux cet
après-midi à l'Assemblée l'enceinte
judiciaire et le seul endroit en
démocratie où se rend la justice
ne se rend pas dans des sénates
politiques des comités de déontologie
Haddock
tous ces monstres en dehors du cadre
légal sont d'ailleurs en train de
dévorer cela même qui les ont créés
voilà les mots forts du ministre de la
Justice et il a d'ailleurs poussé un
coup de gueule exactement de la même
tonalité un peu plus tôt dans la journée
on le verra bonsoir Sarah le grain
bonsoir et merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation député la France insoumise de
Paris membre de la cellule d'écoute sur
des violences sexuelles et sexistes
internes à LFI directement mise en cause
donc par Éric Dupond-Moretti vous lui
répondrez bonsoir Christian Saint-Palais
maître Saint-Palais ravi de vous
retrouver sur ce plateau avocat au
barreau de Paris Anna tomasov militante
féministe qui était à l'origine
peut-être vous en souvenez de ce hashtag
sciences sport sur les violences
sexuelles et sexistes à Sciences Po dans
tous les instituts d'études politiques
de France va nous rejoindre dans un tout
petit instant et puis également sur ce
plateau dans quelques minutes Céline
braque la directrice générale de doxa
parce que ses affaires elles ont
forcément des cons sur l'opinion
publique on va poser les faits pour
commencer de la faire Bayou c'est
l'actualité bonsoir Stéphane de lakowski
bonsoir Myriam bonsoir à toutes et à
tous si j'ai bien compris la
contre-attaque de l'ex patron des Verts
et plutôt musclé la nuit Blacko qui est
tout de suite
[Musique]
ensuite que aucun des comportements
qu'elle dénonçait n'était répréhensible
devant la justice il faut tout de même
préciser que Julien Bayou fait l'objet
d'une enquête interne au sein du parti
Europe Écologie Les Verts et c'est là
que vous allez voir que la cellule
d'enquête est comme Europe Écologie le
vert est quand même extrêmement efficace
je vous explique comment ça s'est passé
le 30 juin dernier Julien Bayou reçoit
un message à son ex-campagne compagne
pardon qui menace de se suicider donc
qu'est-ce qui fait il appelle les
pompiers en appelant il se rend compte
que quelqu'un a déjà appelé les pompiers
il est 21h19 22h19 22h pardon 19 donc
6000 plus tard il reçoit un mail et
cette fois c'est le parti qui lui écrit
donc la cellule d'enquête qui lui dit on
a ouvert une enquête contre vous Julien
pour violence psychologique contre votre
ex campagne donc extrêmement rapide pour
se saisir de l'affaire sauf que depuis
trois mois en revanche ben là on est au
point mort c'est ce que regrette ou même
dénonce l'avocat de Julien Bayou
à 4 reprises à quatre reprises Julien
Bayou a demandé par écrit à être
auditionné devant cette cellule ce qui
lui a été purement et simplement refusé
il est délibérément tenu dans
l'ignorance des faits qui lui sont
reprochés et des accusations portées à
son encontre il n'a donc pas accès au
dossier il ne peut son entretenir avec
aucun membre de la cellule voilà maître
Marie doser l'avocate de Julien Bayou
qui a aussi mis en cause la fragilité
psychologique de l'ex-compagne de Julien
Bayou
de cette rupture qui a eu lieu donc en
novembre 2021 en précisant que dans les
mois qui ont suivi la rupture le
comportement de l'ex-compagne avait été
dit elle fluctuant c'est-à-dire qu'à un
moment c'était plutôt des messages à
base de menaces ou de chantage puis
après des moments où au contraire elle
est plutôt envie de se réconcilier mais
ce qui était le plus frappant moi ce qui
m'a beaucoup frappé dans ce que disait
Marie dosée c'est qu'il y avait vraiment
des messages d'excompagne qui était
extrêmement violent elle va jusqu'à
écrire ta mère te vomit d'où elle est
alors que que elle sait que Julien Bayou
est orphelin qu'il a perdu sa mère
lorsqu'il n'avait 5 ans c'est absolument
affreux pour Julien Bayou qui est obligé
de se justifier ou de sortir de dévoiler
sa vie privée parce que sinon bah il a
aucun moyen de se défendre ce qu'ajoute
l'avocate de Julien Bayou c'est qu'il
pourrait être victime d'une forme de
manœuvre politique je vous rappelle que
dans cette émission nous ne parlons que
de politique et de fait en décembre il
devrait y avoir un congrès des verres
pour désigner une nouvelle direction la
favorite elle s'appelle marine pondelier
elle est soutenue par Julien Bayou mais
Sandrine ruisseau elle Rousseau on est
pris par le compte parodique Sandrine
Rousseau elle
soutient une autre candidate qui est
donc rivale de la liste défendue par
Marine Tondelier et Julien Bayou donc
forcément il y a un soupçon de règlement
de compte en interne c'est ce que dit
l'avocat de Julien Bayou
Julien Bayou constate avec amertume et
colère l'instrumentalisation du juste
combat contre les violences sexuelles et
sexistes à des fins politiques
personne n'ignore que le Congrès des
écologistes se tient en fin d'année
l'ambition politique ne saurait
justifier toutes les croisades
alors qu'elle pourrait être le
dénouement de cette affaire
le résultat de l'enquête interne mais
apparemment d'après ce que dit je crois
libération l'ex-compagne du journal
Bayou pour l'instant n'a pas souhaité
témoigner c'est pas elle qui a saisi la
cellule d'enquête elle veut pas
témoigner donc Julien baroude toute
façon a dit que lui no tiendrait pas
compte des résultats de cette commission
d'enquête donc en fait l'affaire
aujourd'hui une place énorme dans les
médias alors qu'elle n'a aucun fondement
juridique et c'est justement ce qui
faisait pousser un coup de gueule ce
matin à Éric dupont-moretting notre
garde des sceaux je pense qu'il est
temps de siffler la fin de la récréation
on ne joue pas avec nos institutions
la libération de la parole de la femme
oui
même au travers des réseaux sociaux
pour autant les réseaux sociaux ne
peuvent pas être l'uniques réceptacles
sans filtre de cette parole et la
justice doit intervenir on est en train
là de créer une justice de droit privé
qui n'a strictement aucun sens
et pour l'instant tous se passe dans les
médias c'est-à-dire que l'accusation de
Sandrine Rousseau était proférée sur
France 5 la polémique est montée sur
Twitter c'est sur BFM TV que l'avocate
de Julien Bayou a répondu et donc
maintenant on est sur LCP et on se débat
sur le fait est-ce bien normal d'en
arriver là merci merci beaucoup pour
votre pour votre regard Stéphane je
voudrais vous entendre sur cette affaire
alors évidemment on a les faits mais
elle dit quelque chose forcément est-ce
qu'on a basculé dans une forme de d'air
de du grand déballage du tribunal
médiatique de quoi cette affaire
est-elle le nom selon vous est-ce que
c'est le symbole d'une dérive d'une
cause juste est-ce que c'est un
règlement de compte au contraire est-ce
que c'est une victoire du féminisme qui
alerte sainement maître Saint-Palais je
ne sais pas quels sont les motivations
de celles qui quand même a lancé cette
accusation publique parce que c'est ça
le problème c'est d'avoir lancé une
accusation publique sans avoir aucune
légitimité pour le faire donc on parlait
de Sandrine Rousseau qui répondait à une
question posée sur le plateau de France
5 de cette à vous que les plaignons et
les plaignants d'ailleurs au masculin ou
féminin que les plaignants bénéficient
de liberté d'expression totale bien sûr
chacun peut aller dire à l'extérieur
sous réserve de ne pas diffamer ce qui
l'estime être sa vérité mais que
Sandrine Rousseau qui est quand même une
responsable politique qui dit avoir reçu
des confidences d'une plaignante et
qu'il est libre comme sa publiquement ça
c'est la dérive que nous craignons
lorsque ce mouvement a débuté vous savez
nous avons été nombreux les juristes
d'ailleurs magistrats et avocat mais
enfin ceux qui sont au quotidien dans
les dans les enceintes judiciaires à
dire attention
les faits n'étaient pas avérées donc il
y avait en quête judiciaire est-ce que
Sandrine Rousseau serait de poursuite
parce qu'elle n'a pas dit que il avait
été dans l'illégalité elle a dit
d'ailleurs hors plateau que les faits
n'étaient pas répréhensibles mais
qu'effectivement elle ne l'a pas dit en
plateau absolument c'est intéressant de
partir sur la méthode au fond de
Sandrine Rousseau que vous connaissez
bien puisque vous êtes membre de la
nupestre avec elle ici même au Palais
Bourbon comment vous jugez ce qu'a fait
son émotion absolument pas là pour juger
Sandrine Rousseau ni pour juger des
décisions politiques que prendront
Europe Écologie Les Verts comme partie
ou Julien Bayou comme chef de Sparty ou
encore Sandrine Rousseau moi je suis
venue
et j'ai accepté de venir pour parler de
l'importance des dispositifs des
difficultés rencontrées aussi mais de
l'importance de cette typo dispositif
moi je constate
qu'aujourd'hui on a affaire à une
offensive
une offensive bon bien sûr
politique contre les organisations de
gauche qui vivent en ce moment des
affaires de violences sexistes et
sexuelles ce qui est toujours très
pratique pour des adversaires qui
parfois sont fort peu féministes et qui
en profitent pour mener une offensive
mais pour moi l'offensive la plus grave
c'est qu'on a affaire à une offensive
réactionnaire contre les dispositifs qui
sont mis en place de qui parlez-vous qui
mène cette offensive pigment vous voyez
quand le garde des sceaux lui-même
Eric Dupont-Moretti ou encore même pire
la ministre d'égalité des entre les
femmes et les hommes laisse entendre que
ces cellules d'écoute ou que ces
dispositifs qui sont mis en place au
sein des parties se substitue à la
justice voir qu'il serait responsable du
fait du fait qu'il y ait des violences
ou du fait qu'elle ne soit pas traitée
par la justice j'ai moins je suis ici
pour établir des choses et je suis aussi
ici pour parler de méthode et donc
effectivement nous avons une
responsabilité collective à avoir des
dispositifs et des méthodes claires et à
faire attention à ce que nous faisons et
parfois ces méthodes elles sont aussi
contradictoires avec des exigences
médiatiques de
parfois nous devons nous tenir à
certaines procédures c'est ce qui fait
que je n'interviens pas beaucoup je
comprends très bien et je vous remercie
d'ailleurs j'en profite voilà c'est vrai
que les insoumis étaient assez discrets
ces dernières semaines mais je vous
remercie d'avoir accepté l'invitation et
je profite pour dire à nos
téléspectateurs qu'évidemment nous avons
invité et appeler beaucoup de députés
européens il y avait un séminaire de la
nupette enfin aucun n'a accepté
contrairement à vous de venir ceci étant
posé c'est quand même intéressant de
d'essayer de comprendre on va y venir je
vous promets qu'on viendra sur les
cellules d'écoute qui existent dans les
parties de gauche et pas dans les
parties droites peut-être que c'est
d'ailleurs quelque chose qu'il faudrait
changer mais je voudrais vous entendre
sur cette affaire bonsoir anatomazov et
merci d'être avec nous vous êtes une
militante féministe je disais au
présentant le sommaire que vous que vous
avez lancé ce cet hashtag sciencesport
qui a permis de révéler au grand jour
toutes les violences sexistes et
sexuelles dont sont victimes ont été
victimes les étudiants des EP de toute
la France on est sur l'affaire Bayou là
simplement d'entrer dans le détail et
notamment des comités qui font un
travail important au sein des partis
politiques comment vous la regardez
cette affaire on a plusieurs mots qui
viennent certains disent et c'est
l'avocate de Julien Bayou que c'est une
manœuvre que c'est même une
instrumentalisation qui a une forme
voilà de machination politique d'autres
disent que c'est plutôt une victoire du
féminisme une alerte saine comment vous
voyez cette affaire là aujourd'hui c'est
compliqué déjà d'avoir une vision claire
sur ce qui se passe ces jours-ci parce
qu'il se passe beaucoup de choses et on
se retrouve à beaucoup prendre la parole
en tout cas moi ça a été mon cas et je
pense que je ne suis pas la seule et
tout change chaque jour donc c'est assez
complexe maintenant je suis pas là pour
faire de la langue de bois sinon on a
rappelé les faits avant votre arrivée on
a compris qu'aucune plainte n'avait été
déposée que la cellule n'a pas entendu
Julien Bayou même si elle a été saisie
et que on le sait d'après les offres en
dehors du plateau de France 5 de
Sandrine Rousseau rien de répréhensible
n'a été commis est-ce qu'on n'est pas là
dans le symbole d'une forme de dérive
d'une cause totalement juste là en fait
effectivement là c'est une affaire qui
est particulièrement dure à juger je
pense et
comment dire pour les observateurs qui
auraient tendance justement à dire que
c'est un peu
une une justice injuste qui se fait une
justice populaire etc bien sûr que de
fait il est facile de se dire bah voilà
Sandrine Rousseau a quand même tout
intérêt à ce que Julien Bayou Vassy etc
donc il y a plein d'éléments qui a créé
de ça maintenant et moi je reste fidèle
à ma ligne en fait là on est sur
actuellement des des mouvements qui
Cédric de rétablir une vraie justice qui
se font et qui ne sont pas là pour rien
et en fait je crois que le vrai débat
c'est comment on peut améliorer la
justice pour qu'il y ait plus justement
cette espèce de justice de tous les
côtés anarchiques où il y a des tirs de
balles enfin franchement c'est c'est
c'est plaisant pour personne honnêtement
ce qui se passe bonsoir Céline braque et
merci d'être avec nous directrice
générale de doxa notre institut
partenaire vous avez un baromètre à nous
révéler c'est intéressant parce que les
Français nous regardent ils regardent
leur politique et ils attendent de
l'exemplarité vous allez nous donner
dans quelques minutes les résultats
d'une première enquête de popularité on
voit que voilà les dégâts sont
importants dans la classe politique
qu'elle se soit Jean-Luc Mélenchon que
ce soit Julien Bayeux et même Sandrine
Rousseau on va le voir dans un instant
une vraie justice je rebondis sur
l'expression de
anatomasov c'est quoi une vraie justice
en la matière
mais c'est une justice pour laquelle
nous avons dégagé des principes
fondamentaux mais quand je dis le mot
principe maintenant j'ai l'impression
que vraiment c'est cette un ancien monde
plus personne n'en veut c'est ça que dit
le garde des sceaux moi je ne dis pas
qu'on ne peut pas créer d'autres canaux
pour recueillir la parole des femmes qui
se plaignent puisque nous faisons un
constat ensemble et nous disons que la
justice peut être ne va pas suffisamment
vide peut-être que beaucoup de femmes ne
se dirigent pas vers la justice parce
qu'elles savent que en tout cas leur
parole ne sera pas traitée en leur
donnant en tir satisfaction bon donc
nous pouvons réfléchir comment faire
mieux il faut régler le principe de
précaution la mise en retrait par
exemple dans les entreprises on va venir
aux politiques mais dans certaines
entreprises comme il y a une
responsabilité pénale de l'employeur à
protéger ses salariés il y a une mise en
retrait là vous vous êtes vous êtes
favorable à l'idée d'un principe de
précaution complémentaire à la question
judiciaire parce que cela existe ce sont
les procédures disciplinaires c'est le
pouvoir disciplinaire dans les
entreprises
mais ce que nous devons imposer aux
partis politiques qui comme des
associations finalement va le se doter
d'un règlement intérieur en disant ben
écoutez nous allons poser des conditions
pour adhérer un parti puis nous allons
poser les conditions aussi pour exclure
d'un parti d'accord mais il faut poser
les principes ce que défendent du pont
Moretti ce que défend madame Rome vous
devriez quand même vous arrêter un peu
aux objections qui ont été formulées
par cette magie très grande qualité mais
c'est de dire on ne peut pas juger sans
respecter des principes le
contradictoires faire respecter aussi la
confidentialité parce que étaler sur la
place publique et mettre en cause de
l'honneur des mises en cause mais aussi
mais aussi l'honneur des femmes qui se
plaignent parce que quand on est
plaignant parfois on veut que les choses
se fassent discrètement on veut que le
mise en cause soit le responsable soit
sanctionné infiniment courant
et là j'ai été très surpris franchement
madame que vous ne disiez pas voilà
l'affaire Bayou puisque nous en parlions
que vous nous disiez pas immédiatement
voilà un signal d'alerte d'alerte
simplement moi je ne mets personne
encore madame Rousseau est allée
incontestablement trop loin ce
comportement pour moi est inadmissible
mais sans dire quelles sont ses
motivations je n'en sais rien je suis
avocat je comprends mais il faut dire
c'est une alerte pour mes motivation
politique ici moi je vais expliquer
justement comment fonctionne ces
dispositifs et après les
spectateurs jugeront aussi de au cas par
cas si ils ont l'impression que les
dispositifs sont tenus et nous jugerons
aussi voilà je suis parfaitement
d'accord avec vous sur le fait qu'il
faut des procédures et des principes la
première alors mais bien évidemment mais
ça c'est la justice la première des
choses que je voudrais dire ce n'est pas
parce qu'il y a des cellules d'écoute
dans les parties qu'il y a des affaires
de violences sexistes et sexuelle c'est
parce qu'il y a des violences sexistes
et sexuelles ce n'est pas parce qu'il y
a des cellules d'écoute qu'il y a des
femmes qui n'osent pas aller porter
plainte en justice c'est parce que
l'ensemble de la société ne prend pas
suffisamment en compte que ce soit du
point de vue de la prévention de
l'éducation de la formation des de la
justice elle-même et elle n'est pas à la
hauteur aujourd'hui la société en
matière de de justice en matière de
réponse aux violences pack de justice
d'ailleurs de violence de réponses aux
violences sexistes et sexuelles et c'est
aussi pas parce que vous avez des
cellules d'écoute que vous avez des
femmes qui quand elles arrivent au
commissariat s'entendre dire que elles
sont peut-être un peu responsables donc
ces cellules d'écoute elles existent
parce qu'aujourd'hui vous avez des
femmes qui ne vont pas aller tout de
suite à la justice qui parfois
d'ailleurs sont accompagnés par nous
pour aller dans une démarche judiciaire
c'est pas du tout incompatible mais qui
demande qu'au sein d'une organisation
soit pris en compte une alerte
on va voir tout de suite un sujet
absolument de ne pas communiquer
indépendamment de la volonté de la
victime c'est une des règles qu'on va
vous donner et difficilement respectée
dans les maisons sur ces fameuses
cellules d'écoute sur des violences
sexistes et sexuelles au sein des
parties de gauche parce qu'il faut bien
le souligner il en existe que dans les
parties de gauche à ma connaissance la
droite n'en n'a pas encore c'est un
sujet de clé
c'est en 2016 au moment de l'affaire
Denis Baupin que Rock Écologie Les Verts
met en place sa cellule d'enquête et de
sanctions des violences sexuelles et
sexistes elle est composée de 10 membres
dont au moins 5 femmes élues pour 3 ans
5 d'entre eux font partie du Conseil
fédéral du Parti les autres sont des
adhérents sans mandats nationales
internes cette cellule est mentionnée
dans le règlement interne du parti elle
est accompagnée d'un protocole officiel
qui stipule les membres de la cellule
ont reçu une formation à la prévention
et détection des violences sexistes et
sexuelles ainsi qu'aux méthodes
d'enquête par un organisme indépendant
si ces enquêtes n'ont pas de valeur
judiciaires le protocole se veut garant
des grands principes du droit il
respecte les principes juridiques de la
présomption d'innocence du
contradictoire du droit à la vie privée
et du respect des données personnelles
la saisine de cette cellule se fait par
email
le ou la plaignante est ensuite convoqué
par les 10 membres pour un entretien
des témoins éventuels sont également
appelés la personne accusée vient-elle
en fin de procédures la dernière
personne auditionnée est toujours la
personne mise en cause au cas où des
témoignages apporteraient de nouveaux
éléments qu'il faudrait lui soumettre à
la fin de l'enquête la cellule remet un
rapport confidentiel et peu préconisé
des sanctions deux membres du bureau
exécutif du parti et deux membres de son
Conseil fédéral décide alors de donner
suite ou non à ses préconisations Europe
Écologie Les Verts n'est pas le seul
parti à disposer d'une telle structure
la France insoumise est dotée depuis
2018 d'un comité de suivi contre les
violences sexistes et sexuelles dont le
fonctionnement est similaire
le Parti socialiste lui a mis en place
cette année une commission de lutte
contre le harcèlement et les
discriminations elle compte un référent
dans chaque fédération Renaissance le
parti présidentiel prévoit lui dans ses
statues l'installation d'une cellule de
prévention d'écoute et d'alerte mais le
parti précise qu'elle n'a pas vocation à
se substituer à l'autorité judiciaire
enfin à droite les républicains et le RN
n'ont pas de structure de ce type c'est
parti invite les victimes à s'adresser
directement à la justice
[Musique]
Sarah le grain vous avez reçu vous-même
une formation spécifique pour faire
partie de la cellule dalefi bien sûr
alors moi en plus en tant que député en
se pose la question là je suis
nouvellement élu donc je pose la
question de mon maintien au sein de
cette cellule qui ne comporte pas sinon
de personnes à responsabilité comme des
députés donc là c'est on est en train de
réfléchir à ça moi ça me permet en tout
cas de d'expliquer le fonctionnement
parce que c'est une cellule qui est
composée de personnes qui restent
anonymes justement pour pas subir des
pressions et c'est une cellule qui fait
que les coûts chez nous nous avons le
choix nous avons fait le choix d'avoir
un organe qui fait l'écoute
l'accompagnement des femmes et qui
considère que une femme elle va
peut-être pas pouvoir facilement se
diriger vers le comité de respect des
principes de notre mouvement qui est le
comité qui règle tous les conflits mais
vous voyez les conflits de lui il m'a
envoyé un mail qui m'a pas plu il a fait
un tweet qui n'allait pas etc donc des
gens qui ne sont pas forcément habilités
à recevoir la parole comment sont
choisis les membres de cette cellule et
sont nommés c'était des volontaires qui
justement ont accepté tu sais faire ça
ou qui avait déjà pu
donc précisément ça a été contacté par
le par le mouvement et par les instances
du mouvement mais je vous dis que ce qui
compte en tout cas pour nous c'est qu'il
puisse y avoir un accompagnement de ces
femmes et qu'on ne mélange pas les
étapes de la procédure et je crois que
le cœur du sujet est là et au niveau des
temporalités vous avez une procédure qui
écoute les femmes parce que les femmes
elles ont besoin d'avoir un endroit où
elles vont pouvoir être aider à porter
un témoignage si elle le souhaite et
seulement si elle le souhaite en tout
cas nous concernant il y a un témoignage
qui peut être transmis à un comité qui
lui va faire l'instruction va gérer
effectivement le droit du contradictoire
et après ça nous pose plein de questions
quand vous respectez la volonté des
femmes est-ce que jusqu'où vous la
respectez est-ce que une femme qui veut
rester anonyme qui veut pas que trop de
détails sur la transmis à l'homme mis en
cause est-ce que c'est possible parce
que derrière il faut que l'homme la
personne mis en cause l'homme tout état
de cause se retrouvent aussi à pouvoir
répondre de ce dont il est ce qui lui
reconsidéré comme de ces femmes donc
forcément qu'il y ait de plainte pour
bien comprendre la cellule va rapporter
aux parties
signalement qui va déboucher sur une
décision et c'est ça quand il s'agit
d'une candidature tu as à boivent son
soutien ou même d'un élu mis en retrait
voir des missions vous n'avez jamais vu
et vous ne verrez jamais la France
insoumise et mettre des avis de
culpabilité ça c'est le rôle de la
justice c'est le rôle du juge nous nous
la décision qui est prise en politique
et l'édition politique ce sont justement
des décisions qui disent au vu de ce que
nous avons au vu de parce que nous
prenons au sérieux la parole des femmes
parce que nous avons des éléments parce
que nous avons aussi entendu des
témoignages parce que nous avons récolté
des éléments parce que nous avons mené
une enquête nous considérons que il y a
tel ou telle mesure à prendre une
question
vrai que vous que tout le monde entende
ça peut être pour des fêtes sexisme on
va faire une formation ça peut être on
va faire un avertissement parce qu'on ne
veut pas que certaines choses
reproduisent et ça peut être pour
certains cas et ben on va considérer que
par mesure de précaution la personne ne
peut pas être candidate s'il y avait une
investiture en cours ou la personne ne
peut pas rester dans le mouvement juste
pour bien comprendre
nous n'avons jamais communiqué dessus
nous-mêmes parce que sinon nous mettons
en cause la confidentialité que nous
devons aux personnes qui nous parlent
aux femmes qui nous parlent et la
confidentialité que nous devons aussi
aux hommes mis en place
il y a deux sujets il y a la démission
du parti du poste de coordinateur c'est
une démission c'est la sienne donc là si
la justice le disculpait j'imagine que
il ne pourrait revenir c'est sa décision
de vocation
en tant que député il est mis en retrait
c'est-à-dire qu'il ne prendra plus la
parole dans les mystiques mais il est
toujours député si la justice le
disculpait ce qu'il faudrait qu'il
reprenne
vous dit je vous dis je fais partie je
vous pose des questions
c'est justement comment est-ce qu'on a
on articule déjà la demande des femmes
c'est-à-dire que parfois vous avez des
femmes qui ne témoignent pas auprès de
nous et donc on ne sait pas comment se
saisir leurs paroles parfois le témoigne
dans les médias donc on peut se saisir
de la parole qu'elles ont donné dans les
médias et parfois sur les médias sont
dans les médias sont étalés des paroles
de femmes qui ne nous sont pas arrivés
et j'aimerais que tout le monde saisisse
les difficultés dans lesquelles qui nous
met aussi et qui serait celle de toute
personne un peu honnête qui se pose ces
questions là
comment vous regardez vous l'avocat
l'homme de droit c'est cellules est-ce
que ce sont des alliés de la justice ou
pas
alors moi je ne vais pas les
disqualifier vraiment de revers demeure
franchement j'ai une approche un peu
plus un peu différente sans doute que
c'est le cas exprimé le garde des sceaux
très très vive presque violente non la
cellule de l'écoute pour recueillir la
parole mais tous les lieux qui
favorisent la parole et l'expression
d'une plainte ça me paraît tout à fait
favorable ensuite cessez avec
l'hypocrisie dans la présentation vous
dites mais nous nous accusons personne
c'est ce que j'entends sans arrêt mais
non mais la justice vous ferait après
nous nous accusons personne mais si
lorsque quelqu'un est obligé
démissionner de quitter son poste bien
sûr qu'il est affiché comme coupable
d'un fait alors bien sûr vous ne donnez
pas de qualifications pénales mais vous
dites il est parti parce que nous
l'avons estimé coupable de violence sur
son
et parce que nous prenons au sérieux la
parole des femmes et parce que le risque
le risque de se retrouver avec un
agresseur dans le mouvement nous semble
un risque je me fais important je me
permets de venir
ce que vous faites homme et femme quand
même dans les lieux de pouvoir c'est
garder la parole ça je peux vous dire il
y a pas de différence entre les hommes
et les femmes non mais ce que j'explique
non mais ce que je vais vous dire quand
même vous avez dit nous croyons la
parole des femmes le slogan que vous
avez posé les autres là vous avez dit
nous prenons au sérieux mais vous avez
dit les femmes ont les croit quand elle
se plaignent voyez le problème de la
procédure contradictoire si je pose ce
postule là quand j'ai la prétention
comme vous le faites de juger
c'est-à-dire de dire si l'effet sont
établis et quand vous posez comme un
postulat les femmes je les crois là vous
minez tout c'est ça que nous reprochons
certainement pas vous prendre la parole
c'est que vous venez juste de dire qu'on
juge on prétend juger on prétend dire si
le dossier ne nous donne des éléments
qui nous font penser qu'il faut qu'on
prenne une mesure de précaution vous
dites aussi
jamais vous verrez un document écrit
pour remarquer ou un document on aura
dit que les faits sont établis on
considère qu'on a des dossiers où on se
dit bah il y a des raisons d'être
inquiet il y a des raisons de prendre
des décisions et des précautions et ces
précautions là on aimerait bien ne pas
avoir à les prendre mais on les prend
parce qu'il y a des violences sexuelles
dans la société et qu'elles ne sont pas
toujours prises en charge par la justice
dans des temporalités qui nous
permettent
une décision nous soyons sûr vous
comprenez le principe de précaution
c'est protéger toujours la plaignante la
protéger mais attention concilier avec
la présomption d'innocence et donc si
vous êtes sûr pourquoi pas on peut dans
une enceinte comme une association être
sûr mais à condition d'avoir une
procédure équitable et on a envie de
dire qui es-tu pour juger ça n'est ça
n'est pas un débat de anatomazov comment
vous vous regardez cette mise en cause
au fond de du travail de ces cellules
parce que il est évidemment complexe il
est très délicat mais il est aussi
parfois
mise en cause et on le voit bien que il
y a un dysfonctionnement il ne marche
pas dans l'affaire bayouille il y a un
problème manifestement mais après j'ai
pas envie d'avoir une vision binaire de
la politique mais les parties de gauche
qui ont été cités et qui sont équipés de
ces cellules sont des parties qui sont
progressistes qui veulent faire
progresser la société donc ce qui se
passe et qui a été très mal expliqué
c'est qu'en fait
peu importe derrière en fait si on est
dégagé justement dans les médias sur les
réseaux sociaux par les commentateurs je
crois que le but d'abord c'est de dire
si un homme choisit de s'engager dans
ses parties il sait à quoi ils
s'engagent et il sait sur quoi il vient
chercher des voies il vient chercher des
voies sur la défense du droit des femmes
et justement sur le fameux on te croit
etc alors bah le jour où lui-même est
accusé de violences sexistes et
sexuelles en fait c'est de lui-même qui
part enfin ça semble assez logique nous
sommes sur des sur des hommes qui
choisissent d'aller dans des parties qui
sont progressistes éradicalement
féministes donc évidemment que bah ils
doivent aussi faire des des pas en avant
pour
justifie-t-elle parfois des décisions
dans des accusations à tort qui ont des
conséquences sociales sur une vie mais
je crois qu'il y a pas de solution
parfaite par contre les accusations à
tort c'est un truc qu'on entend tout le
temps dès qu'on parle de justice ou de
déni de justice et en fait les
accusations à tort c'est vraiment
quelque chose c'est un à deux pour cent
des accusations enfin je veux dire c'est
quand même assez rare alors c'est grave
mais c'est jusqu'à pondéré quand même je
crois alors on va regarder avec vous
maintenant Céline comment réagit
l'opinion les Français ont voilà
manifestement digéré toutes ces affaires
et on voit que les lignes bougent dans
vos enquêtes au doxa on commence par
Jean-Luc Mélenchon après l'affaire
catenens qu'est-ce qui se passe dans le
pingouin est-ce qu'il se fracasse contre
cette affaire avec ses prix dans ses
affaires là on a les accusateurs les
accusés ceux qui défendent les accusés
Jean-Luc Mélenchon fait partie de
ceux-là puisqu'il a défendu Adrien
gatnens et quand on regarde dans le
baromètre qu'on publie tous les mois
quels sont les personnalités qui ont le
plus souffert dans l'opinion il se
trouve que c'est Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui
perd le plus de plumes si je puis dire
ainsi dans l'opinion puisqu'il chute de
six points avec
22% de code d'adhésion ça le fait
dégringoler dans le top 10 il se trouve
maintenant largement en dessous de
Marine Le Pen alors qu'il était à peu
près autant voilà il avait autant de
supporters et auprès en plus même chez
les sympathiques oui pardon il dévisse
effectivement encore plus auprès des
sympathisants de gauche puisqu'il recule
de 8 points alors on précise quand même
qu'il est sauvé par l'absence de
concurrence aux yeux des gens en tout
cas d'une personnalité qui aurait la
trempe de Jean-Luc Mélenchon il reste
quand même le préféré des sympathisants
de gauche avec une côte d'adhésion qui
est de 55 % on voit qu'il y a des dégâts
donc pour Jean-Luc Mélenchon mais aussi
dans l'ensemble de la nuqueuse oui
c'est-à-dire que ce que l'on voit ce
mois-ci c'est que rien ne bouge
quasiment à droite mais les choses
bougent beaucoup à gauche et ce grand
déballage est vraiment vu comme tel en
tout cas par les Français ce qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui et bien on voit que
Adrien catenas par exemple qui faisait
vraiment partie des espoirs des
sympathisants de gauche se retrouvent un
peu parmi les barrières
voilà de quand on regarde les
personnalités qui suscitent le plus de
rejet alors voyez le mot est fort mais
c'est comme ça que c'est posé c'est à
dire qui rejetez-vous alors Eric Zemmour
est toujours le plus rejeté mais juste
derrière on a Jean-Luc Mélenchon puis
Marine Le Pen derrière Adrien cadenas et
Sandrine Rousseau qui tous les deux
progresse si l'on peut dire ça ainsi
puisque c'est un peu la cote de
l'infamie dans cette cote de rejet
forcément les mises en cause mais aussi
ceux qui accusent les accusateurs aussi
sont moins bien perçus par les Français
quand vous disiez voilà finalement les
Français vont peuvent prendre un peu de
recul non pour l'instant c'est pas ça
c'est que on voit un grand déballage ça
plaît pas tellement aux français même si
on va le voir alors justement plus de
transport qu'est-ce qu'ils attendent les
Français quand on les interroge sur la
transparence justement alors c'est une
question intéressante la transparence de
la vie privée parce que on se demande
toujours jusqu'où un homme politique
doit aller dans la transparence de sa
vie privée et jusqu'où les autres
doivent valider pour rendre transparente
sa vie privée et là les chiffres sont
impressionnés
qui nous disent aujourd'hui on attend
des hommes et des femmes politiques
qu'ils soient de plus en plus
transparent sur leur vie privée alors
vous dites peut-être non mais c'est ce
que disent les gens et alors comme si on
baise à l'aide alors c'est intéressant
vous disiez non parce que exactement on
dit souvent ça et ils ont dit souvent ce
sont les jeunes qui demandent de plus en
plus de transparence et c'est l'effet
réseau sociaux en fait c'est pas tout à
fait ça parce que ceux qui réclament le
plus de plus le plus de transparence ce
sont justement les seniors c'est à dire
on a les trois quarts des 65 ans et plus
on est un peu en retrait chez les moins
de 25 ans un peu plus gêné avec cette
histoire de de transparence sur la vie
privée et alors il faut mettre en
relation avec un autre chiffre et nous
vous nous mettez en garde contre c'est
quasiment un français sur cette Français
sur 10 qui veulent la transparence de la
vie privée quand on interroge sur
l'exemplarité des politiques là les
hiérarchies sont un peu différentes mais
c'est à dire que c'est intéressant de
savoir après ok les hommes politiques et
les femmes politiques doivent être
exemplaires mais ce qui compte aux yeux
des gens et en fait le vrai sujet pour
les gens c'est l'argent largement c'est
à dire à 67% ils nous disent c'est
là-dedans c'est vraiment ce sujet là
parce que c'est de l'argent public qu'on
confie et qu'on paye des hommes
politiques avec de l'argent public et
c'est là qu'on les attend plus que sur
les questions de mœurs en matière
écologique même si les jeunes le disent
beaucoup ils sont 50% de le dire à le
dire en matière de non violence comme si
c'était des sujets qui n'avaient
finalement pas complètement rapport avec
leur fonction et que les gens mettez un
peu en reculer dessus et vraiment ce
sujet d'argent en vrai c'est le sujet
quand on pose des questions spontanées
dans nos sur les hommes politiques c'est
toujours toujours celui qui ressort en
premier bien avant les questions alors
qui restent importantes mais c'est je
veux juste mettre en garde sur ce
mémoire miroir un peu déformant du
moment autour de ces affaires merci
beaucoup baromètre odoxar trouver chaque
mois en exclusivité pour les chaînes
parlementaires vous avez le mot de la
fin Sarah le gras parce que le débat
s'achève vous avez parlé n'est pas
étonné par ces chiffres moi je suis pas
étonné mais quand vous parlez de vie
privée je crois que le la question n'est
pas celle-là les gens attendent qu'on
vous parlez de d'argent et ils veulent
vérifier qu'il n'y a pas un problème de
corruption ils veulent vérifier qu'il
n'y a pas que des gens qui abusent de
leur pouvoir et une des façons d'abuser
de son pouvoir aussi c'est de perpétrer
de façon impunie des violences et là
dessus sur le grand déballage je suis
désolé mais si la gauche elle c'est
parce que il en est question mais où
êtes-vous pour Pierre cabaret visé par
une plainte pour agression sexuelle et
harcèlement morale déposée par une
ancienne collaboratrice c'est un député
à rom personne n'a jamais entendu parler
Benoît Simian poursuit pour harcèlement
contre son ex-femme il avait elle avait
un téléphone grand
dangereux ils ont refusé de lever
l'immunité dans le dernier mandat la
majorité la majorité je vous parle même
pas de Damien Abad et et
Darmanin c'est encore autre chose Jérôme
oui mais je vous dis que il y a des
hommes qui sont accusés aujourd'hui
allez on en fait il y a des hommes qui
sont accusés aujourd'hui dans des
parties qui très facilement mettre la
lumière sur les parties de gauche qui
décident de se servir de ces
questions-là
vous savez les non-lieu et les
classements sans suite ça veut pas non
plus dire je vous propose une chose je
pense que vous quelque chose qu'on va
continuer à parler de tous ces sujets on
est au début d'une nouvelle on voit bien
que les politiques tatonnes et il faut
quand même le préciser si les cellules
d'écoute sont mises en cause notamment à
gauche c'est parce qu'il en existe et
aussi parce que les femmes prennent la
parole et ce qui est ses affaires voilà
ne leur donnons pas envie de se taire
merci à vous ne leur dites pas de ce
terme merci infiniment d'être venu sur
le plateau d'elcp on va présenter notre
grand témoin c'est un grand diplomate il
a été ambassadeur en France de France
pardonnez-moi en Israël aux États-Unis
ou encore auprès de l'ONU ils signent
l'histoire diplomatique chez Grasset le
son d'hier pour le monde d'aujourd'hui
le moment
occidental est arrivé à son terme nous
dit-il et nous devons nous réhabituer à
vivre une tragédie Gérard nous rejoint
dans un instant juste après l'invitation
de Clément mairie regardez
si on vous invite Gérard arrow c'est
parce que la guerre est de retour en
Europe les combats en Ukraine ne
faiblissent pas les conséquences
géopolitiques sont chaque jour plus
perceptibles et Vladimir Poutine sous
pression brandit la menace nucléaire
les rapports de force et les coups de
bluff Gérard arrot ça vous connaît sur
votre CV une collection de postes
prestigieux ambassadeur de France en
Israël aux Nations Unies puis aux
États-Unis au fil du temps vous avez
imposé votre marque de fabrique une
forme de parler cache qui détonne dans
le milieu feutré des ambassades il est
scandaleux que le Conseil de sécurité
n'est pas pu agir pour exercer une
pression sur les autorités syriennes un
franc-parler peu commun et des manières
parfois cavalières avec les chefs d'État
que ce soit avec le président français
en visite à Washington
Warek Donald Trump le soir de son
élection vous brisez alors tous les
codes de la diplomatie en postant ce
tweet
après le brexit et cette élection tout
est désormais possible un monde
s'effondre devant nos yeux un vertige au
petit matin Jean-Marc Ayrault manque de
s'étouffer en découvrant votre message
l'ambassadeur français a fait part de
son vertige
a bien failli vous coûter votre poste
pionnier de la diplomatie du tweet vous
savez aussi prendre du recul vous
publiez histoire diplomatique leçon
d'hier pour le monde d'aujourd'hui un
manifeste du réalisme en diplomatie que
vous illustrez concrètement en plaidant
pour un dialogue avec Vladimir Poutine
la diplomatie c'est pas pour diégocier
avec les Belges ou les Luxembourgeois
c'est pour négocier avec le diable nous
sommes dans une jungle où il y a pas de
juge il y a pas de gendarme la guerre se
terminera par une négociation avec
Poutine si Poutine est encore le chef de
l'État à Moscou vous expliquer en
conclusion de votre livre que la
politique étrangère c'est parfois
accepter le détestable pour éviter
l'insupportable mais pour paraphraser
Churchill le risque n'est-il pas alors
d'avoir le déshonneur sans éviter la
guerre
bonsoir Gérard arrot et merci infiniment
d'avoir accepté notre invitation va y
venir à vos histoires diplomatiques
c'est passionnantes se plonger dans le
passé de ses grands accords de paix pour
essayer de mieux comprendre le monde
dans lequel on a basculé mais pour
répondre tout de suite de la question
que vous est posée par Clément Méric le
risque d'avoir élaguère et le déshonneur
faut-il continuer à parler à Vladimir
Poutine vraiment après boutcha après is
you mais après maintenant la menace
nucléaire si on si on imagine qu'une
paix possible et c'est un grand si parce
que aujourd'hui je vois mal aucune des
deux parties ne veut négocier donc je il
est difficile d'imaginer un règlement de
paix s'il y a une négociation elle se
fait avec l'ennemi et en général et
l'ennemi s'époutine donc s'il y a une
paix elle sera négociée avec Poutine
sauf naturellement si les Russes se
débarrassent de lui donc pour vous les
Britanniques et les Américains ont tort
de ne plus vouloir directement
officiellement parler à Poutine comme le
fait notre président français vous savez
à la fin du compte les négociations elle
sera entre Zelinski et Poutine c'est aux
Ukrainiens de négocier c'est aux
Ukrainiens de décider quand ils veulent
négocier à quelles conditions ils
veulent négocier et vous trouvez que la
voie diplomatique française a été
efficace elle a été utile ses heures de
coup de fil passé franchement vous savez
les évangiles 10 € les Pacificateurs et
donc je pense qu'il était il était
nécessaire de tout faire pour éviter le
pire et le président de la République a
tout fait pour éviter le pire je pense
que c'est une une noble tâche même s'il
n'a pas il n'a pas réussi mais on sait
maintenant que même en le rencontrant
Poutine avait déjà décidé d'envahir
l'Ukraine est-ce que la meilleure au
fond de solution diplomatique Gérard
arrose ce ne serait pas tout simplement
la victoire des Ukrainiens pour sauver
leur souveraineté nationale avec avec
notre aide militaire dans cette guerre
est-ce que vous la croyez possible cette
victoire des Ukrainiens ça dépend ce que
vous appelez victoire évidemment il faut
souhaiter la victoire du crânien il
repousse les qu'ils repoussent les
Russes ensuite la question se pose de
savoir par exemple pour la Crimée est-ce
que est-ce que les Russes accepteraient
la perte de la Crimée est-ce que il ne
considérerait pas là que leurs intérêts
vitaux sont en jeu donc c'est aux
Ukrainiens de décider quand ils veulent
négocier mais oui il faut qu'il y ait
une victoire des Ukrainiens c'est-à-dire
il faut que l'envahisseur soit défait
ensuite les termes de la paix ça c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué à essayer
d'imaginer le monde était très ce matin
sur la doctrine nucléaire bousculée dans
ces temps où l'arme atomique est menacée
par Vladimir Poutine d'abord est-ce que
est-ce qu'on est en train de changer
d'air très clairement sur cette question
là est-ce que vous ne croyez capable
d'employer cette arme même tactique et
s'il le fait est-ce que alors à ce
moment-là on rentre automatiquement nous
membres de l'OTAN dans une guerre
mondiale alors d'abord vous savez les
Russes dans leur expression
reste quand même relativement prudent et
relève dans les limites de ce que
j'appellerais la doctrine de la
dissuasion classique ils disent si les
intérêts vitaux de la Russie sont en jeu
donc
ils agissent ils agissent évidemment la
menace mais ils le font dans des termes
qui ne sont pas qui ne sortent pas la
doctrine traditionnelle de la dissuasion
ça c'est la première chose deuxième
chose est-ce que pourrait être l'usage
de l'arme nucléaire ça c'est la première
question parce que il va pas utiliser
l'arme nucléaire sur l'armée ukrainienne
qui est évidemment entremêlée avec avec
les troupes russes quelle est la cible
qu'elle pourrait être la cible et
troisièmement la Russie serait alors
totalement isolée dans le monde parce
que il n'y aurait pas un pays qui ne
manifesterait pas son indignation donc
tout est possible mais je crois que nous
n'y sont pour le moment non mais
évidemment si par exemple l'armée russe
s'effondre si les Ukrainiens rentrent en
Crimée peut-être que la situation
changera mais pour le moment je n'y
crois pas on le voit déjà à ce que a dit
la Chine les premières positions les
premières réactions ou celle de l'Inde
alors votre livre est un manifeste du
réalisme en politique étrangère ce sont
vos mots dans quel air nous sommes
rentrés sans gendarmes du monde et bien
justement on a eu après la guerre froide
on a eu les deux gendarmes soviétiques
américains puis ensuite le moment de
Triomphe américain avec le gendarme
américain le gendarme est fatigué on l'a
vu à Kaboul il rentre chez lui et
parallèlement vous avez des puissances
qui émergent ou qui émergent la Chine la
Russie l'Inde et donc on est dans un
monde de puissance dont le la logique
est uniquement l'intérêt national on le
voit par exemple pour l'Inde l'un
évidemment n'approuve pas pour Poutine
n'approuve pas l'invasion de l'Ukraine
mais l'un il trouve son intérêt comme ça
elle a du pétrole pas cher vous revenant
de la Russie et donc elle reste à
l'écart du conflit et donc c'est ça
c'est un monde de grand carnivore où il
n'y a plus de Givors et de guerre vous
dites qu'au fond il va falloir s'hab au
retour de la guerre il peut y avoir vous
ne pensez pas que c'est la dernière en
Europe cette guerre loin de là on parle
de Taïwan en Chine pour la Chine mais
vous pensez qu'en Europe il peut y avoir
la guerre peut-être de retour ça veut
dire que pour les Européens il faut pas
se préparer à la guerre mais il faut
tout faire pour l'éviter il faut donc
qui est il faut se réarmer parce que
avoir une bonne diplomatie il faut avoir
un bâton derrière le dos mais pour ne
pas voir à l'utiliser et puis il faut de
nouveau il faut négocier négocier
négocier le moment occidental arrivait à
son terme qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
est-ce que c'est les puissances de
l'Ouest qui sont moins puissantes ou
est-ce que ce sont ces valeurs qui sont
moins puissantes dans le monde c'est la
puissance c'est la puissance
comparativement les États-Unis resteront
la première puissance mondiale pour des
décennies qui sont devant nous mais
comparativement vous avez à la fois une
certaine affaissement de l'Europe en
termes comparatif et vous avez la montée
de nouvelles puissances comme la Chine
et l'Inde et ses puissances il faut se
rendre compte que l'OCC domine le
système international et donc c'est
puissances en font au fond nous envoie
le message en disant mais c'est fini on
doit vous devez travailler avec nous
dernière question avant que vous
puissiez réagir aux chroniques de nos
affranchis et elle concerne également
l'Ukraine avec vincent Hugeux je suis
sûr que vous le connaissez sur le
Conseil de sécurité je rappelle que vous
avez été ambassadeur de France aux
Nations Unies vous avez vu ce qu'a dit
Emmanuel Macron il est pour une réforme
du Conseil de sécurité on ne peut pas
laisser un droit de veto éternellement à
des puissances comme la Chine ou la
Russie c'est faisable franchement ce
n'est pas faisable
pour réformer le Conseil de sécurité il
faut l'accord des cinq membres
permanents donc de la Russie et de la
Chine et des deux tiers de l'assemblée
générale c'est impossible il n'y aura
pas de réforme du Conseil de sécurité
histoire diplomatique c'est grâce à
leçons d'hier pour le monde
d'aujourd'hui c'est absolument
passionnant on passe du Congrès de
Vienne au traité de Versailles aux
accords de Munich qui voilà résonne
parfois avec avec l'actualité Gérard
arrot vous restez avec nous
d'accueillir nos affranchis pour leur
parti pris ce soir les hamboncelles
revient sur la victoire de Georgia
Meloni la candidate d'extrême droite en
Italie le grand reporter Vincent Huger
qui va vous intéresser puisqu'il va nous
dire pourquoi selon lui la mobilisation
partielle en Russie est déjà par terre
et puis le regard de Stéphanie
Despierres sur le boycott des députés en
soumise l'équipe de foot de l'Assemblée
contre la présence des joueurs du
rassemblement national nos affranchis
les voici bonsoir bonsoir à vous trois
Vincent on commence avec vous Poutine et
sa mobilisation
boomerang vous nous dites que la
mobilisation ordonnée par par Vladimir
Poutine il y a du fiasco dans l'air dans
l'air et au sol d'ailleurs cette
mobilisation a beau être partielle elle
n'en est pas moins par terre ou
demeurant la pelle aux armes serait-il
impeccablement chorégraphié qu'il ne
changerait pas la donne sur le champ de
bataille ukrainien du mois tant que
perdure les carences structurelles d'une
armée qui depuis 7 mois collectionne les
bourdes logistique défaillante
équipement obsolète encadrement porté
disparu motivation en berne de tout
corps sauter par une rigidité toute
soviétique le processus est de plus
plombé parce que le Kremlin range
pudiquement dans la rubrique erreur des
erreurs le sexagénaire diabétique de
Volgograd pris dans la nasse la
sage-femme de l'oral somme mais sous
peine de poursuites de troc et sa blues
contraint treillis quid des étudiants
exemptés ou pas il aura fallu trois ou
quatre décrets pour statuer sur leur
sort donc des cafouillages des erreurs
avec des guillemets bien sûr de nature à
brouiller le message du devoir
patriotique comment de fait s'étonner de
l'ampleur de l'exode des réfractaires
selon le FSB le renseignement intérieur
plus de 260 000 russes ont quitté le
pays en une semaine cap sur la Finlande
la Turquie la Géorgie ou le Kazakhstan
encore un effort camarade et si ce n'est
pas déjà le cas le contingent des fuyard
dépassera celui des réservistes
officiellement rappelés à ce stade soit
300 000 pour échapper à la rafle
certains se cognent la tête sur un mur
ou un capot de voiture à s'en fendre le
crâne
un peu éprouvante d'autres navigue sur
internet en quête de la méthode la plus
efficace pour se casser une jambe ou un
bras comme si les troupes expédiées en
Ukraine manquaient de bras cassés alors
rébellion isolé ces images ou début
d'une lame de fond contestataire en
Russie regardons-nous bien sûr de
surestimer le phénomène il n'empêche là
révolte gronde notamment loin de Moscou
dans les provinces reculées au dakestan
bouriaci les plus déshérités celles qui
ont déjà payé le plus lourd tribu à un
conflit qui ne sera jamais le leur les
premières pourvoyeuses de Shera canon
mais aussi celle où les réseaux de
solidarité familiales et communautaires
restent les plus robustes on a vu des
femmes un vectiver en termes crues des
policiers interloqués on a vu prédire
coûte qu'en Sibérie un jeune rappelé
tiré sur un officier recruteur tandis
que flambé saela des bureaux
d'enroulement incendiés au cocktail
Molotov est-ce que ça veut dire toutes
ces images qu'on découvre en même temps
que votre chronique et bien
signifie que Poutine a perdu la main sur
ses propres terres il aura lui-même
tendu le piège dans lequel il se débat
en décrétant cette mobilisation
pagaieuse le Kremlin fait entrer la
guerre pardon l'opération militaire
spéciale dans chaque foyer de
Saint-Pétersbourg à Vladivostok
impossible désormais de se réfugier dans
le déni ou l'indifférence affichée le
tsar Vladimir rond ainsi le pacte social
c'est les implicitement avec ces sujets
vous me laissez conduire à ma guise le
char de l'État en contrepartie libre à
vous de bricoler un quotidien via voilà
ce qui advient quand on remobilise bien
malgré soi le peuple qu'on croyait avoir
démobilisé pour de bon Gérard raro ce
que vous pensez que au fond Poutine est
en train de tomber dans son propre piège
avec cette mobilisation il peut soulever
le pays je sais pas s'il soulèvera le
pays mais comme vous le vous le dites
c'est très frappante dans les
talk-shauts qui sont des sortes de
délires nationalistes vous avez les
journalistes dont plus proûtiniens que
Poutine qui reconnaît ce même qu'il y a
des problèmes et qui en appelle au Père
des peuples d'essayer de le corriger
donc ce qui veut dire que c'est un vrai
problème et c'est je crois là là vous
avez cette parfaitement votre je partage
votre conclusion jusque là la guerre ne
pénétrait pas dans les dans les foyers
russes là la guerre pénètre dans les
foyers Russes et les Russes sont en
train de dire qu'ils ne veulent pas de
cette guerre
on verra on verra si la pâtit russe
sera terminée si on sort du déni vous
allez suivre ça un son pour nous et je
vous en remercie Léa vous voulez nous
parler ce soir de ce qui s'est passé en
Italie tremblement de terre alors j'ai
appris que vous aviez des origines
italiennes puisque vous avez des
origines génoises et vous vouliez réagir
à la victoire de George Jamel on
absolument yossonnot
c'est ainsi que Georgia Meloni s'est
présenté lors d'un métier d'un meeting
pardon dont la séquence d'ouverture est
devenue virale sur internet je suis une
femme c'est sur ça celle qui sera
vraisemblablement la prochaine chef du
gouvernement italien a décidé de mettre
l'en phase elle se présente comme une
femme avant de se présenter comme une
responsable politique d'extrême droite
qui surf sur le fascisme comme si le
fait qu'elle soit une femme nous
permettait d'oublier qu'elle est
aujourd'hui il y a une des figures
politiques les plus redoutées en Europe
comme si le fait qu'elle soit une femme
nous permettait aussi d'oublier qu'elle
était la personnalité politique qui
représente la plus grande menace pour
les droits des femmes et des minorisés
aujourd'hui en Italie Georges a fait de
son identité de gens finalement un atout
politique alors qu'elle porte elle-même
un projet profondément anti féministe
mais ce n'est pas la seule justement
cette stratégie là on l'a vu déjà à
l'oeuvre en Europe et dans d'autres dans
d'autres pays en dehors de nos
frontières naturellement à l'étranger
bien sûr mais aussi en France on voit
que régulièrement des femmes de droite
ou d'extrême droite se sert en fait du
fait qu'elle soit des femmes pour venir
nourrir finalement des réformes qui sont
profondément contre les droits des
femmes et aussi les droits des personnes
qui sont socialement dominées c'est
particulièrement inquiétant à plusieurs
égards notamment parce que ces femmes
n’hésitent pas non plus instrumentaliser
des causes comme la lutte contre les
violences sexuelles et sexistes pour
très souvent nourrir un discours et des
mesures profondément racistes il y a
aussi des risques parce qu'en fait ces
femmes viennent reproduire alimenter des
des postures patriarcales contre celle
contre quelle les femmes essaient de se
soustraire depuis des siècles elles
viennent d'ailleurs être véritablement
les chevilles ouvrières d'un système
d'oppression et d'exclusion qui est
l'antithèse même de ce que pourrait être
un projet qui se voudrait féministe
c'est à nous journaliste oui de
condamner ça je pense qu'effectivement
on a on a une certaine responsabilité
dans dans ce qui est en train de se
passer parce que ces femmes sont souvent
perçues comme étant légitimes aux yeux
d'électricités qui pourraient être mal
avisés ou pas suffisamment avisé et qui
pourrait être effectivement victime de
cette confusion des gens et qui
viendrait finalement nourrir
l'imaginaire collectif qui vient à dire
que si c'est une femme elle va
nécessairement faire des choses
positives pour les femmes et bien c'est
faux il faut s'en méfier et je pense
qu'il faut qu'on soit là pour souligner
en fait ces incohérences et ses risques
ces risques vraiment de confusion il
faut aussi qu'on saisisse toutes les
opportunités nous journalistes
observatrices observateurs de la vie
politique pour rappeler que l'extrême
droite lorsque c'est en France lorsque
c'est en Europe ou ailleurs dans le
monde ne jamais avec des projets
politiques qui soient profondément
démocratique mais plutôt pour avec des
projets qui soient qui sont généralement
liberticides et antidémocratiques merci
Léa Gérard arrow portes ouvertes à
Marine Le Pen ça dure mélodie quand on
parle de recul de droit des femmes et de
femmes de pouvoir frapper moi dans le
discours de mélodie c'est qu'elle dit
qu'elle est elle est féministe et
ensuite elle dit qu'elle est favorable à
la famille traditionnelle on sait bien
très bien ce qui a derrière le mot
famille traditionnel ce n'est pas une
structure particulièrement féministe que
la ce qu'ils appellent la famille
traditionnelle mais nous il y a non
seulement les femmes et moi ce qui
m'avait frappé par exemple Florian
Philippot qui est gay celui aussi au nom
de ça essayer de dire vous voyez bien
que le Front national n'est pas ou le
ressemblant national n'est pas une
menace pour pour les minorités sexuelles
puisque je le suis moi-même il faut donc
se méfier de cette logique qui est en
effet peut-être assez dangereuse et
faire oublier la réalité merci Gérard
déjà terminé avec une histoire plus
insolite mais en même temps très
politique Stéphanie vous nous apprenez
ce soir d'abord qu'il y a un match de
foot de l'équipe de l'Assemblée
nationale et qui il n'y aura pas de
joueurs insoumis sur le terrain pourquoi
non pas d'un soumis et pas de socialisme
car la gauche veut boycoter le match qui
était prévu demain soir au pied de la
Tour Eiffel entre l'équipe des
parlementaires et une équipe d'anciens
joueurs de foot et de et de stars la
nupesse ne veut pas porter le même
maillot que les députés du RN et encore
moins courir après le même ballon écouté
nous ne voulons pas participer à
finalement un objectif de récupération
politique par le rassemblement national
pour se banaliser donc on considère que
le sport c'est un outil de tolérance
c'est un outil qui véhicule certaines
valeurs et en l'occurrence taper sur
l'épaule de ceux qui ne partagent pas
nos valeurs ça nous paraît pas opportun
alors Emmanuel bléri député
rassemblement national et Gaulle de
l'équipe renvoie la balle à la gauche
j'ai envie de dire déjà qui sont les
extrémistes parce que leur sectarisme
est un marqueur de déjà de l'extrémisme
les députés rassemblent national ont été
élus par les Français nous disaient à
juin dernier on est pas arrivé à
l'Assemblée nationale en humilité en
écrasant en marchant sur sur l'assemblée
on est venu emprunter le peuple ce match
de foot en l'occurrence vient servir une
bonne cause qui est celle de la lutte
contre le cyber-harcèlement moi j'allais
dire on va porter le même maillot et
marquer des buts en face ensemble bon
ils ont décidé de se mettre à l'écart
ils prennent leur responsabilité par
rapport à ça alors la gauche n'a pas
toujours eu ces états d'âme car les
insoumis et le rassemblement national
ont déjà couru côte à côte sur un
terrain mais de rugby cette fois sous la
précédente législature la revue Charles
avait même consacré un article au pilier
de cette équipe l'insoumis Alexis
Corbière et le député rassemblement
national à Louis à lui aujourd'hui mère
de Perpignan alors c'était en 2017 et en
2018 aujourd'hui la polémique c'est sur
le foot et cette vol qu'elle concerne
car le livre qui a un député de la
majorité et capitaine de cette équipe
qui estiment que le sport devrait
dépasser les clivages
c'est à dire que les étiquettes doivent
rester dans le short et que quand on
propose d'être dans une équipe de
football parlementaire une sélection
parlementaire dans sélection il y a
sélection ces personnes savaient que
l'ensemble des collègues parlementaires
allaient aller jouer je trouve dommage
cette espèce de stérilisation cette
espèce de fébrilité ça en dit long
malheureusement sur l'état actuel des
troubles de Monsieur Mélenchon
sauf que depuis l'enregistrement il y a
quelques heures c'est interview avec un
député à Renaissance et bien la patronne
des députés de la majorité à demander au
parlementaire renaissance de ne pas
participer à ce mari en expliquant ne
jouons pas dans la même équipe ni
extrême droite ni extrême gauche alors
est-ce qu'il y aura assez de monde sur
le terrain demain pour le match rien
d'émotion bon ben merci merci pour ces
informations Gérard rareau le sport doit
dépasser la politique et on sent que
voilà maintenant 89 députés RN c'est
plus la même chose que de jouer au club
de rugby de l'Assemblée où ils étaient
une poignée et puis là aussi c'est la
stratégie de d'opposition frontale qui a
choisi laupes donc ils ont ils ont en
ont fait un peu leur marque de leur
marque de ma de politique à mon avis
Deschamps qui sait comment faire quand
on a une hécatombe de blessés et puis le
marabout de Paul Pogba qui pourrait
peut-être
jolie pirouette on verra alors on sera
là pour pour voir nos députés jouer sur
le terrain contre d'anciens joueurs de
l'équipe de France
en fait intéressant de voir ça si le
match a lieu merci à vous merci les
affranchez et merci beaucoup Gérard
d'être passé par le plateau de LCP
histoire diplomatique le son d'hier pour
le monde d'aujourd'hui c'est-à-dire chez
Grasset très belle soirée documentaire
avec Jean-Pierre Grassin à demain même
[Musique]